ausgerechnet Greta Thunberg ausgerechnet
sie wird für die Grünen und Robert
Habeck in der großen Kernkraft
Diskussion jetzt zur Gefahr Greta
Thunberg eigentlich ja die Ikone der
Grünen die macht jetzt drucken die
deutschen Kernkraftwerke die sollen
nämlich länger laufen wenn sie doch eh
schon am Netz sind ja Greta thünberg
also gegen Robert Habeck plötzlich
stehen sich die beiden politisch frontal
gegenüber und das eben auch noch direkt
vor dem grünen Parteitag der Sommer
gespannt in der Kernkraft Frage und auch
diese Entscheidung von Robert Habeck die
sorgt unter Klimaschützern unter
Umweltschützern für heftige Diskussion
die wird vielen von denen nicht
schmecken für die Sicherheit der
deutschen Energieversorgung nämlich will
er nun auf der Nordsee schwimmende
ölkraftwerke einsetzen wahre Klima
Dreckschleudern
rund 140 Meter lang 35 Meter hohe
Schornsteine und eine Bestückung mit
Brennkammern die in Turbinen Strom
erzeugen diese Kraftwerk Schiffe sollen
uns vor einem eisigen Winter retten
warum weil Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck vor allem ein Problem hat er will
absolut und definitiv keine
Atomkraftwerke doch dieser Plan hat
einen gewaltigen Haken denn diese
Schiffe sind vor allem eins gewaltige
Umweltverschmutzer um Strom zu erzeugen
muss Öl verbrannt werden von harbex
Ministerium heißt es dazu die belgische
Firma exma hat der Bundesregierung über
die deutsche Botschaft in Belgien
Angeboten bis zu drei Kraftwerk Schiffe
mit jeweils bis zu 450 MW elektrischer
Leistung auf Basis von Öl in Deutschland
zu installieren faktisch könnten diese
drei ölschiffe den Strom erzeugen den
das AKW Lingen bis zu seiner Abschaltung
Ende 2022 erzeugt laut der zuständigen
Landesregierung in Niedersachsen haben
die drei Schiffe allerdings einen
CO2-Ausstoß eines mittleren kohlek
Handwerks und das mitten in der
weitgehend geschützten Natur der
Nordseeküste die Opposition ist entsetzt
unionsfraktionsvize und Energieexperte
Jens Spahn zu Bild die Ampel verbrennt
lieber die Klimakiller Kohle und
Schweröl statt alle CO2-neutralen
Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu lassen
angesichts drohender Blackouts ist es
unverantwortlich
ist das also wirklich Robert habecks
Plan Deutschland für eine Blackout zu
bewahren Umweltverschmutzungen mit noch
mehr Umweltverschmutzungen zu
kompensieren
tja über den Umweltsünder Harbeck müssen
wir natürlich sprechen im Studio das
bildchefredakteur Johannes Boje schönen
guten Morgen Johannes guten Morgen ja
machen sich Habeck und die Grünen jetzt
komplett unglaubwürdig ich fürchte ja es
geht ja jetzt schon seit einer ganzen
Weile so dass sie alles dafür tun um die
Atomkraft zu vermeiden und mittlerweile
schwenken Sie auf Linien ein die man
eigentlich nur von wirklich schlimmen
umweltverschmutzenden Ländern viel
ärmeren Ländern als unserem kennt
und sie haben keine Hemmungen da immer
weiter zu gehen ich meine so Schiffe vor
der Küste ankorn zu lassen was bislang
nur ein Plan des Ministers ist er
diskutiert darüber mit der
Betreiberfirma aber das erinnert
wirklich an sehr sehr arme Staaten wo
man sagt okay alle Kraftwerke an Land
sind kaputt gegangen sind vielleicht in
einem Krieg zerstört worden jetzt
ankommen Schweröl Tanker vor der Küste
verbrennen dort Öl irgendwie schwarze
Wolken ziehen Richtung Strand alles nur
auch weil man die Atomkraftwerke nicht
mehr weiterlaufen nur ideologische
Gründe die sind Robert Habeck dann
offensichtlich wichtiger als die
Umweltpolitik so sieht's aus also es
wurde ja von den Grünen sowieso sehr
lange bestritten dass es überhaupt ein
Stromproblem gäbe also legendär sind ja
Sätze wie wir haben gar keinen Strom
Problem wir haben gasproblem und so
weiter und so fort jetzt dämmert ihn wir
haben ein ganz massives Stromproblem
alle haben Angst vor Blackouts im Winter
vor Blackouts ganz generell weil eben
einfach nicht genügend Strom verfügbar
ist in diesem Zeitraum
lustigeren Bundesminister der ja
geschworen hat zum Wohl des deutschen
Volkes zu arbeiten alles daran setzen
dass die Stromquellen die wir haben
weiterlaufen das sind die Atomkraftwerke
es sind sichere Atomkraftwerke es sind
moderne Atomkraftwerke es gab in
Deutschland auch problematische
Atomkraftwerke diese sind zum Glück
abgeschaltet bin ich auch sehr dafür
aber wenn ein Land nicht genügend Strom
hat wenn die Leute wirklich Angst haben
müssen im Dunkeln zu sitzen da muss man
ja sagen wir tun jetzt alles dafür dass
die Energiequellen die wir haben auch
weiterlaufen und das schafft er eben
nicht stattdessen investiert er in die
schmutzigste dreckigste Energie
überhaupt
so kommt es eben das ausgerechneten
grüner Bundesminister der größte
Umweltverschmutzer wird das vor dem
grünen Parteitag kommt also sozusagen
zum Duell Greta Thunberg gegen Robert
Habeck wer setzt sich dadurch also
fallen die Grünen Oma am Ende
ja ich glaube schon dass in der Partei
massiv diskutiert werden muss denn jeder
der den Klimawandel ernst nimmt jeder
der Sorge vor einer globalen Erwärmung
hat jeder der gegen Emissionen kämpft
muss jetzt sagen okay wir setzen weiter
auf Atomkraft das kann man auch zwei
Wege tun man kann sagen
Atomkraft war schon immer sicher wir
haben tolle Kraftwerke lasst uns das
Weitermachen man kann auch sagen
Atomkraft ist großer Mist das sollte es
nicht geben aber wir brauchen jetzt eine
Brückentechnologie die beiden Wege gibt
es und zumindest für den letzten Weg
werden sich die Grünen eigentlich
entscheiden müssen sie haben nur das
Problem sie sind so stark geprägt von
den 80er 90er und Jürgen Trittin spuckt
da im Hinterkopf noch Rum da ist eine
ganze Generation die geht komplett auf
die Barrikaden wenn die Grünen die
Atomkraft weiterlaufen lassen weil diese
gesamte Generation dafür gelebt hat den
Atomausstieg zu bekommen ja und das ist
das Problem der Grünen aber es ist für
Sie natürlich eine äußerst äußerst
unangenehme Lage von der obersten
Umweltschützerin der Welt Greta Thunberg
sich sagen lassen zu müssen lass doch
bitte die Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
das wird ein spannender Parteitag da
werden wir auf jeden Fall drauf schauen
danke schön Johannes Boje Johannes Boje
[Musik]